[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to once again
be discussing hogwarts headmaster albus
dumbledore more specifically we're going
to be honing in on one particular aspect
of his character his name and unpacking
its meaning
witness for the defense albus percival
wolfrick brian
straight from the man himself this is
dumbledore's full name and we're first
exposed to it during harry's
disciplinary hearing that takes place
before the wizard gamut apart from this
scene dumbledore's entire name isn't
really touched on again and it made me
wonder where do these names come from
two middle names is uncommon enough i
have two but three there must be a
reason for that
today i'm going to be unpacking each and
every one of albus dumbledore's names
starting with albus
dumbledore's first name albus is
actually the latin word for white which
bears a positive connotation
being a symbol for things that are good
this works well in contrast with
voldemort who is commonly referred to as
the dark lord yin and yang
while the latin root is most likely the
primary motivation for his first name
it's also possible and some fans are
convinced of this that he was named
albus in order to honor the character of
gandalf or more specifically gandalf the
white from lord of the rings
this however would not be a suitable
in-universe explanation as it breaks the
fourth wall percival
first and foremost it should be
mentioned that percival is the name of
albus dumbledore's father and it's
certainly not uncommon for children to
be named after their parents we also
know that his father percival was
imprisoned in azkaban while albus was
still very young
the name percival is an old french name
which means pierce the veil and stems
from the old french words meaning pierce
and valley
percival was also one of the esteemed
knights of king arthur and notably the
only one at arthur allowed to see the
holy grail the oldest recorded reference
to percival in this particular tale
comes from de trois 12th century
romance count du krol
wolfrick there is less of an
identifiable relationship between albus
and the name wolfrick but if we look at
its historical context there are a few
ways that it makes sense
wolfrick is an anglo-saxon name
comprised of two components wolf wolf
and rick rich powerful it is widely
identified simply as wolf power and the
name likely alludes to the power the
dumbledore's figure exhibits it's also
possible that wolfrick is an homage to
wolfrick of hazelbury a 10th century
anchorite a miracle worker from somerset
england fun fact i was born in somerset
wolfrick is said to have received the
gifts of prophecy and healing and was
involved in many miraculous happenings
he became known as a healer of body mind
and spirit for all those who sought him
out
brian
brian which at first glance may not
appear to exude the same sort of
etymological grandiosity as some of his
other names actually has a lot more
depth to it than you think you see brian
is a male given name of celtic origin
that means hi or noble
some sources even report that the name
brian is synonymous with strength so
while it may not sound like much when
matched up against wolfrick or percival
the name is still very much fitting of
the strong hogwarts said master because
of the name's commonality it also
provides a sort of eccentric and comical
edge which is befitting of his character
dumbledore since harry potter first came
out the name dumbledore has been
plastered everywhere it's on hundreds of
millions of pages and products across
the world and as a name it has become
entirely synonymous with harry potter
however what a lot of you may not know
is that dumbledore is actually the old
devon word for bumblebee
when jk rowling was choosing a name for
dumbledore's character she'd like to
imagine him humming to himself a lot
which is why she drew inspiration from
the bee
and that pretty much sums up the
etymology behind all of the names of
hogwarts most famous headmaster
though of course just because we've
covered his names it certainly doesn't
mean we've covered his titles which
officially include order of merlin first
class headmaster of hogwarts supreme
magump and chief warlock of the wizard
gamut
and unofficially include the champion of
commoners and the greatest sorcerer of
modern times
no dumbledore certainly isn't short of
names and that's it for this video did
you learn something new about dumbledore
as always leave your video suggestions
down below
until next time remember
time will not slow down when something
unpleasant lies ahead
[Music]
you